at first this is from Andy from Newport
News Virginia
Brendon Theo what up gang gang buzz buzz
coming into this video here two three
and outs on the last two drives trying
to get first down here let's try it
again my first two videos weren't funny
enough for you I've got a little debate
club for you let's go with what is
better the National Football League or
college football Brendon this especially
pertains to you I was just wondering
maybe trying out for nose guard for the
Patriots next week you know South saw
what the scales were saying about you so
[Laughter]
dude here's that here's what I like the
NFL because someone's getting paid
n-c-double-a you're basically watching
Django with football helmets you know
I'm saying yeah I think you might be
onto something there I like um what do I
like in c-double-a Tom Brady's 48 years
old and he's getting paid 21 million a
season now he's just busting nuts and a
supermodel throwing touchdowns that's
why I like the NFL I also got the
Cleveland Browns
they were [ __ ] two years ago now there's
a [ __ ] well we'll see if they're good
okay they also have one of the biggest
egos in the game or they'll become and
whatever the other guys hey Baker make
[ __ ] the guys from just could you
interview the guy from last chance you
don't talk football might be your daddy
same cloth I saw I saw an interview bolt
that you guys had the same answer they
said what's the number one thing you
overcame this year you both said a
Quentin Tarantino movie I don't even get
that joke but I'll say this dude that
you um he didn't coach Division five
foot what I'll say is this dude the NFL
I think is I like watching that end
product a little bit better because I
think I was just raised more in it as a
Saints fan but you weren't a LSU fan
college football I was a little bit but
not crazy there's nothing like big-time
college football
you just said you know hold on hold on
you got the bands playing you got the
Alumni there yeah you got the Boosters
I agree nobody getting paid set for the
college yeah and the kids aren't jaded
really so they're playing for the love
of the [ __ ] LSU Tigers or yeah we're
out of buffalos however it's a little
sad though it is sad you know most of
them gonna go on do [ __ ] last chance
you most likely but most of them I think
you're still getting the dreamers out
there at the certain point with the NFL
it gets a little bit different
especially with the contracts um
as big as they are in the NFL or most
these guys even still playing the play
or they just playing to stay in the pay
in the pay grade I don't give a [ __ ] I
think you do that one says what if we
hear any ones don't care I think some of
that gets effective once it's like oh
[ __ ] if I play so hard that I'm gonna
kill myself or that I'm gonna get hurt
then am I gonna play as hard because I
gotta be back next year to make the
money it's like you got to come back and
make the money whereas college yeah I
think you still get a lot of action
Jackson's out there you know a lot of
people that are in it for the love of
the game
I'm gonna go college I'll go to college
dude I'm gonna NFL just because like I
said college is 12 years of slave with
football helmets on I don't [ __ ] with
it yeah but college is also a lot of
those guys wouldn't even be going to
college if for more for football so it's
like that's not a good argument that's
not the slave drivers say sale oh well
they're getting education no they're not
they're majoring in football no some of
those dudes came and read and they get
degrees then that don't learn [ __ ] if
they don't want to learn to read that's
their [ __ ] [ __ ] bro no it's not
because they're not encouraging to read
they're encourage them catch footballs
they're encouraged millions of dollars
off of them Wow look I agree the college
to make it money they should share with
the players I agree with that
but I don't think that the players
shouldn't be held accountable at all
they don't want to get education then
look here's the thing they either make
it to the pros or let's be honest if
you're a tall black guy you go work at
the airport after so it's one or the
other brah
but I'm just saying it's my say we got
to take responsibility for ourselves
it's like you know anything colleges
fault to [ __ ] get you know give you
an education now I would demand that
they give you four years whether you get
injured or not that you get to finish
your degree no matter what some of them
do
I would demand that and I think some of
these guys should have more negotiating
I think they should get a fund that you
know five years down the road
or whenever that they start getting paid
you let's see if they're selling jerseys
oh dude you kidding me
the collars making so much money bro and
then the colleges don't care if people
get educated anymore that just becomes
about football no they don't care as
long as you're moving tickets also
they'll be cool and the teachers let you
pass class is in season soon seasons
done you're [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah dude I remember uh oh [ __ ]
I don't even remember
you think you played football for twenty
nine sixty nine percent wait with NFL
yes different animal cuz it's not it you
don't feel a sleazy watching like you
know those dudes are gonna have brain
trauma in four years it's kind of what
you signed up for I like when people
complain a brain trauma the NFL are
fighting it's like complain [ __ ] yeah
then you got sugar on your shirt if you
a baker
you [ __ ] Baker you if you're [ __ ]
Michael Phelps you get wet save your car
oh that's I'm saying a lot of this [ __ ]
everybody just find that that's what
happens man you know they're warriors
yeah dude I don't know if I'll come on
King in the sting I'm gonna say dumb
[ __ ] from working with you you know and
you're gonna say dumb [ __ ] it's what
happens when we get together that's what
we do yeah dude I ain't gonna follow a
lawsuit in two years at us
oh man I was saying all this dumb [ __ ]
dumbasses Knicks we got Randy from
Harrisonburg wait hold up you got
something ol boy do you like
n-c-double-a or NFL let me NFL man and I
fell but I mean I do agree with the Oh
daddy yeah they should pay the players
and all that but you know hey learn to
read bruh oh yeah take a second out
that's not how it's brought up they
don't force it on you your major in
football they should learn to read
that's you even caves in hieroglyphics
they had a couple little words up their
cat lamp
fire alien yeah well they're reading
signs though you know I'm saying yeah
but you watch a lot me that some of
these kids they don't give a [ __ ] about
that you know if you know that one out
of 300 guys makes it out of college and
you gotta do a little bit of your
studying man yeah with you man you're
preaching right there
am i cuz you take another side
I'm just telling you how it is for the
majority of him yeah I went through the
program I know exactly what the [ __ ]
they're doing I got a double major cuz I
knew my ass wasn't gonna go to the end
did you yeah
that's your mom Emily I bet you were in
some shitty band I bet is there any
pictures of you playing ball let's keep
this [ __ ] train